man wollte diesen krieg auch für
metallen mit mit diesem sprengstoff
sollte einen anschlag auf das
rotlichtviertel händels werk verlegt
werden hier wollte man zuschlagen
die eine seite produziert hatte also
satte daran gegenüber den hells angels
es ging tatsächlich darum wirklich
diesen klub hier in deutschland zu
etablieren dann hat auch die gegenseite
das nicht auf sich sitzen lassen und
zurückgeschlagen
der brandanschlag erfolgte auf dem
grundstück meiner familie und das macht
eigentlich deutlich dass das ein pulver
swatch kann bestätigen dass von
handgranaten bis panzerfäusten über
kalaschnikows alles da was man zu den
krieg braucht
[Musik]